good morning well you know there could
be a lot of heat and a lot of wind
out at the lake but today seems like
it's going to be a great day to have a
little fun out there on the water
the best way to do that how about a boat
colville bay marina is located on the
northwestern side of the lake and
sally hadimio takes us to gives us a
look at what's available
for the day or perhaps maybe a weekend
out on the water
lake mead and mojave have been my home
for the last
22 years chad taylor works for lake mead
mojave adventures he is fortunate to
live in such an impressive area
paulville bay specifically where we are
today
somewhere i lived when i was a little
bit younger and have been
running around and houseboating for
almost
20 years now houseboating is making
waves this summer
a staycation or vacation for the entire
family
houseboating kind of died off over the
last couple of
probably over the last 10 years and
we've recently seen a spike
and reservations while houseboats offer
luxury amenities for days
there are other watercrafts available so
we have a
16 foot fishing skiff would be like a
small aluminum boat
two to three passenger deck boat which
is around an eight to ten passenger boat
next to that we have a
ski boat which has a tower on it that
people would usually use for
wake boarding skiing or actually getting
somewhere on the lake a lot
quicker their main goal for families and
friends to make
memorable experiences you could get
anywhere into two
or three hundred dollars and upwards of
six
seven hundred dollars to the patio
pontoon boats
would be around nine hundred to eleven
hundred dollars for a day
the cowbell bay area has many secluded
coves to soak up the sun
fish and even spot desert bighorn sheep
once they get out here
it's some of the most surreal settings
sally jaramillo reporting from lake mead
oh that was so wow doesn't that look
refreshing
i'm here hi beyonce